das gesellschaftliche ereignis steht die
eröffnung des google büros hier in
berlin
und es sind nicht weniger als 850
menschen die sich hier in einem doch
übersichtlichen überschaubaren büro
angemeldet haben das heißt es wird
trocken voll und das scheint schon
anzupacken
so groß und so sieht das mir haus hier
tomaten mozzarella sie dir so aus und
das in speyer
meine damen und herren das ist cherno
jobatey
der ist bei etwas das nannte man
fernsehen und das haben alle leute
früher geguckt
offensichtlich ist man das mit was ist
das vegetarische kwh was immer das auch
sein mag
naja
oder doch enge boden
izmir ein kerneuropa der früher mal
millionen mensch bekannt war
aber achten sie auf dieses gesicht sich
diesen mann
dieser mann ist der thomas gottschalk
von übermorgen
er ist der franken fällt dabei ganz klar
wenn man gut herr kollege warnt mich
sehr an eine klamotte musste ich habe
das von dem geklaut aber das weiß heute
keiner mehr
also der frankenfeld von jetzt also
beister seidling mit apfel und sellerie
das ist brigitte zypries die mit der
mitte die mit dem browser im browser
wieso das
das müssen wir mal google
sie sind dafür verantwortlich
mitverantwortlich dass man nur noch 100
euro zahlen muss wenn man beim musik
klauen erwischt wird beim ersten mal
zumindest genau darf ich danke sagen
danke vor zyklus vielen dank sie haben
die welt ein stück besser gemacht
meine damen und herren jetzt werden wir
erfahren wie dieses hier heißt also der
ehemalige bundesministerin wird jetzt
erklärt was das hier ist achtung sagen
sie mal bitte von vierte kartoffeln mit
gebratenem rinner tata und majoran sind
sagt eigentlich eine bulette mit
kartoffelbrei das hätte ich auch gesagt
dass nämlich auch guten appetit so
norbert röttgen ist auch hier im büro
erst nicht ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen geworden
aber vielleicht finden sie ihren job ja
ich habe ja ein ich bin
bundestagsabgeordneter okay aber ich
google das büro schlechter so dass es
wirklich gut ich habe es gerade gesagt
es ist anders als alle anderen die ich
jedenfalls kenne das heißt jetzt viel
fantasie unterwegs gewesen
es ist eher ein land sehr positiv sehr
oft finde es gut das ist guido knopp
sind sie noch beim zdf
ich bin noch im zdf die letzten monate
ich dachte sie würden jetzt schon ein
bisschen vom ruhestand so party machen
und das war die google einweihungsparty
in berlin ab jetzt wird ihr gearbeitet
sondern geht es um gema um
leistungsschutzrecht und netzneutralität
und dazu befragt die promis beim
nächsten mal ist an twitter